chocolate food of the gods that's the
Greek meaning of Theobroma cacao the
name of the tree that provides it for a
plant which is notoriously difficult to
cultivate its takeover of global tastes
is decidedly impressive although not
sold in Britain until the 1650s its
history goes back about two-and-a-half
thousand years before that when it was
almost certainly first domesticated in
Central and South America
chocolate was an important part of early
Central and South American culture the
classic Mayans and their successors
including the Aztecs consumes chocolate
usually as a drink with water and
perhaps chili or thickened with maize
they also use the beans as currency as
well as using them in ceremonies from
baptism to burial it was a rich person's
beverage imbued with health and
spiritual properties and inevitably when
the Spanish invaded and colonized the
areas where it was found their doctored
it for their own use
at first it was slow to spread when one
Spanish ship transporting beans was
captured by the British in the 16th
century they apparently threw the cargo
overboard thinking it was some bull done
however as the Spanish and then the
French and then the Italians adapted the
drink for their own tastes they replaced
the water with milk and added sugar and
also started drinking it hot by the time
the British cotton Don it was a rich
thick concoction both delicious and
pleasing exotic it was also healthy 17th
century medicine wasn't always certain
what the new foods from the Americas
would do to a Western disposition but
chocolate mainly got a resolute thumbs
up taken correctly it was said to
restore natural heat generator blood in
live in the heart and conserve the
natural faculties it was also claimed to
be enough for dizzy AK and one author
wrote to lay cold women young and fresh
creates new motions of the flesh and
caused them to long for you know what if
they were taste of chocolate the market
assad was said to be addicted to it
using it to fuel ferocious orgies no
wonder it was popular at this time
chocolate was a drink but in the early
19th century manufacturers worked out
how to remove much of the fat called
cocoa butter which could then be added
back carefully to improve the texture
making it edible though still very
bitter
the defatted chocolate became cocoa
powder which allowed the poor access to
their own version of the food of the
gods it was also used for cooking though
we have to wait a few more decades for
chocolate cake it wasn't until the
second half of the 19th century that
developments in milk process
a sharp reduction in the price of sugar
and fierce competition between
confectionery companies resulted in the
first really popular eating chocolate
milk chocolate sales exploded and
chocolate quickly came to mean the stuff
you ate not the stuff you drank less
than 50 years later chocoholics could
choose from an ever-increasing range of
bars boxes and novelty shapes today
Chopra is polarized from cheap milky
sugary stuff to high-end black bars of
joy the former we're told high in sugar
and fat is leading to an a beast nation
for the latter it's hinted may actually
be beneficial early studies suggest
small doses of very dark chocolate rich
in antioxidants theobromine and caffeine
may make us happier healthier and less
stressed perhaps those 17th century
chocolate lovers were right after all
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to recieve
notifications for new videos see you
again soon